hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
Monday September eight today and you're
watching games for news first up today
we know who's starring in Resident Evil
Revelations to the upcoming survival
horror game is set to feature series
regular Claire Redfield as well as more
reverting the daughter of Barry Burton
within the November 2014 issue of Game
Master magazine we also got a glimpse of
the plot the events of Revelations two
will take place chronologically between
rezzy five and six and according to
producer Mitch eter Okabe it's going to
have a bigger survival horror foetus a
new and creepy enemy type called the
afflicted will be introduced and the
campaign will support co-op play with
Claire as the main character engaging in
combat and maura serving as general
support next up Batman Arkham Knight has
a release date and got a bunch of
information about its collector's
edition Warner Brothers has announced
that the game will be heading to xbox
one ps4 and PC on jun 2 of next year if
you don't mind the idea of dropping
dollars like you're Bruce Wayne you may
want to grab the two-hundred-dollar
Batmobile edition for consoles this
price the Edition includes a custom art
book a limited edition steelbook a comic
book an exclusive character skin pack
and a fully transformable Batmobile
statue which actually sounds super
awesome if 200 bucks is a bit out of
your price range but you like the idea
of getting some sweet batman arkham
knight march along with your game
there's also a 100-dollar addition to
console or PC which includes most of the
goodies from above but replaces the
Batmobile statue with a batman memorial
statue which is as it suggests a
memorial statue of Batman finally
Activision has announced that destiny is
the most pre-ordered new IP game in
video game history alongside the
milestone Activision Publishing CEO Eric
Hirshberg expressed his belief that
destiny is pleased to follow the same
trajectory as halo predicting we
that we have the opportunity to launch
something huge not just into the gaming
landscape but the popular culture
landscape arriving at our launch day
with this much support and enthusiasm
from fans and retailers is downright
exciting moments like this just don't
come around very often Bungie added that
they have been excited about making this
game world for years and that they're
glad to be providing a multiplayer
experience where players can take on
epic action packed adventures if you'd
like to take a look at the most
pre-ordered game in history you can
check it out on gamespot right now where
we're hosting a live stream as for our
question of the day let me know if you
started getting into destiny and what
you reckon so far that is it for me
today if you'd like more newsy type
things you can check out stories on
minecraft and the sims 4 on site now and
I'll see you tomorrow